[موسيقى]
في يوم الساب عش من يوليو العام الماضي
اعلنت الحكومه اليمنيه الشرعيه استعاده
عدن من قبضه الحوثيين وقوات الرئيس
المخلوع ايام قليله وتمر الذكرى الثانيه
اذا ففي اي حال اصبحت العاصمه المؤقته
لليمن التطور الاحدث تمثل في عمليه سطو
مسلح على مبنى البنك الاهلي في المنصوره
بعدن هذا الحدث الامني يضاف الى احداث
سابقه ويتزامن مع احتقان سياسي وترد في
الخدمات في عدن والجنوب عموما ليس البنك
فقط الذي تعرض للسطو في عدن فواقع الحال
ان الامال العظيمه التي حلم بها كثيرون عن
عند استعادتها تحولت خلال عامين فقط الى
خيبات تقرير مريم
اويش ليست لقطه من فيلم بوليوود انها عدن
في يوم من ايام الفوضى الامنيه في وضح
النهار جرت عمليه سطو بنك المدينه وهو
الرئيسي منذ نقل البنك المركزي من صنعاء
الى العاصمه المؤقته للحكومه الشرعيه لم
يجد اللصوص الذين يرتدون الزي الرسمي
لقوات مكافحه الارهاب اي صعوب
لارتكاب جريمتهم دخلوا البنك وخرجوا امنين
رسميا تخضع عدن لسيطره قوات الحزام الامني
ووحدات مكافحه الارهاب التي تشرف عليها
دوله الامارات اعادت الحادثه جدلا لم
يتوقف هل فشلت ام افشلت الحكومه الشرعيه
للوفاء بوعودها
للعدني اصطدمت كثير من التوقعات بعد اعلان
تحرير عدن من ميليشيا الحوثي وقوات الصالح
قبل عامين
بواقع مغاير تماما ماذا تحقق منذ الساب من
يوليو تموز
2015 الكثير من الفوضى الامنيه والسياسيه
وخيبات الامل والكثير من الازمات
الانسانيه حتى رئيس الحكومه الشرعيه عبد
رب منصور هادي لم يستطع المكوث فيها طويلا
وظلت اقامته فيها على فترات متقطعه لم
تستطع الحكومه الشرعيه الوفاء بتعهداتها
والتزاماتها تجاه المواطنين لاكثر من سب
شهدت عدن اغتيالات في وضح النهار واحيانا
لشخصيات خرجت عن بيت الطاعه الاماراتي
ظهرت تنظيمات مسلحه بمسميات مختلفه ولا
يعرف لماذا وكيف عاد تنظيم القاعده وفروعه
بقوه في المنطقه يرى بعض المحللين انه من
الظلم تحميل الحكومه الشرعيه وزر كل ما
يحدث وخطايا اهل الارض والقادمين اليها
باجنه مشبوهه ولكنها ايضا ليس برئه تماما
من تدهور الوضع سياسيا
واقتصاديا لماذا تفتقر للنفوذ اللازم لوقف
اطماع الانفصاليين مجلس انتقالي جنوبي ليس
هذا ما كان اليمنيون ياملون من تحرير
الجنوب وكل شبر من ارض البلاد من جماعه
انصار الله وقوات صالح عدن غارقه في
الظلام اكثر من اي وقت
مضى قطاع في التيار الكهربائي بهذه النسبه
منذ 100 عام قالت الحكومه انها رصدت مبالغ
من تبرعات ومن التحالف العربي لمعالجه
الازمه المبلغ المعلن يكفي لتوفير 1200
ميجا وات اي ضعف ما تحتاجه عدن لماذا اذا
تستمر معاناه
المواطنين لماذا تستمر اذا معاناه
المواطنين اليمن في زمن الحرب والنزعات
الانفصاليه كوليرا من يعيد له مجده
وسعادته ينضم الينا من اسطنبول الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اليمني ياسين التميمي ومن
نيويورك الباحث السياسي اليمني احمد
الصالح مرحبا بك سيد ياسين التميمي كيف
يبدو لك المشهد في عدن بعد عامين من
استعادتها اسعد الله مسائك يا اخت سلمى
ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره وضيفك الكريم
عدن تبدو في هذه اللحظات مظلمه على
المستوين المادي والمعنوي مظلمه لانه لا
توجد كهرباء لا توجد خدمات كما كان يتوقع
اليمنيون ومظلمه معنويا لان فرص الحريه
التي كان ينشدها اليمنيون من وراء التحرير
كلها تلاشت تقريبا كما ورد في تقريركم فرص
العيش المشترك هددت بقوه في عدن وضربت
بقوه ايضا شهدت عدن خلال العامين الماضيين
اول عمليه تهجير قسري في تاريخ اليمن
على هذا المستوى او على الاقل نستطيع
القول انها ثاني عمليه تهجير قصري الاولى
تمت عن طريق الحوثيين والثانيه تمت عن
طريق الحراكيين المدعومين من الامارات اذا
نحن للاسف الشديد بعد سنتين مما يسمى
تحرير عدن غير متفائلين بالنتائج التي
تحققت هذه
اللحظه هناك نموذج ربما يتشكل على يد
الامارات يشابه تماما نموذج الانقلاب الذي
تشكل في صنعاء على على عين اكثر من طرف
اقليمي ودولي في صنعاء تشك نموذج انقلابي
مثله او كان راس
حربته الحوثيون وفي عدن تشكل يتشكل اليوم
نموذج
انقلابي تصنعه الامارات بامتياز وهذا
اليوم هذا النموذج يوضع بشكل واضح امام
الحكومه فيعمل على تعطيل دورها ويهدد
وجودها ويكفي ان نقول ان الرئيس عبد الرب
منصور هذ وهو رئيس الدوله ليس موجود بعدن
ولا يستطيع العوده الى عدن في هذه المرح
صالح يعني كيف تنظر الى المشهد من وجه
نظرك ومن هو المسؤول ولصالح من هذا المشهد
في عدن بعد
عامين اسعد الله مسائكم جميعا والساده
المشاهدين الحقيقه انا اختلف تماما عن ما
قاله ضيفك وعن حتى بعض التلفيقات في
تقريركم يعني عدن قبل عامين من اليوم كانت
مرتع للارهاب والجماعات المتطرفه
الارهابيه تسير نهارا جهارا في الشوارع
وتسيطر على معظم اراضي المدينه والجميع
يعرف ذلك عدن كانت يعني خارج اطار خارج
اطار الدوله وخارج اطار المقاومه ولكن بعد
عامين من اليوم دعيني اتكلم على
الايجابيات اكثر من منطقه مدينه عسكريه
كامله او منطقه عسكريه كامله للمخلوع صالح
تم خروجها كاملا اكثر من 200000 جندي امن
مركزي تابعين للمخلوع صالح تم اخراجهم من
هذه المدينه تم تامين المدينه جزئيا بناء
على الامكانيات المتاحه وبناء على
المعطيات التي متوفره وبناء ايضا على
التناقضات السياسيه بين الاطراف التي هي
تعمل ضد بعضها البعض لكن هناك اشكاليه
واضحه تماما في اداء الشرعيه ومؤسساتها
حيث انها لا توجد هناك تناغم وتجانس بين
مؤسسات الشرعيه بين الحكومه والرئاسه وبين
المقاومه وبين حتى اجزاء من التحالف لكن
هذا الامر لا يعني باي حال من الاحوال ان
عدن تعيش في وضع اسوا عدن اليوم هي افضل
مما كانت عليه في تلك الفتره صحيح بان
هناك تحديات وهناك اشكاليات كبيره جدا
تتحملها الحكومه ليس
التحالف التي تتحدث عنها يعني ليست الا
حاله قاتمه من المشهد في اليمن الجنوبي في
عدم بالتحديد الخدمات غير موجوده
الاستقرار الامني غير موجود
الاغتيالات الفشل في تامين يعني المنشات
الرئيسيه الحكومه الشرعيه لا تستطيع ان
تاتي وتمارس مهامها في عدن وذلك بسبب
الاغتيالات المتكرره فعن اي يعني مشهد
ايجابي تتحدث مقارنه مع ما
اي ما هو واقع وما نراه ومع تحفظي ايضا
على ما تقول بانه نحن نبث الفقه نحن لا
نبث الفقه وانما نقل الواقع بكل
مصداقيه الواقع لديه صورتين تنقلون صوره
التي تريدونها والصوره الاخرى لا تريدون
نقلها لكن دعيني اقول لك بما هو واضح كانت
عدد الاغتيالات القائمه نسبيه يجب ان
اتكلم عليها بالارقام وليس بما نريد نحن
كان عدد الاغتيالات في عدن في تلك الفتره
مرتفع جدا عدد العمليات الارهابيه التي
تستهدف الموظفين وقاده المقاومه كانت
كبيره جدا عدد عمليات السطو والسلب والنهب
كانت كبيره جدا المواطنين في عدن في تلك
الفتره لم يكونوا يستطيعوا الذهاب حتى الى
جامعاتهم والى مدارسهم والى اعمالهم اليوم
البلد تعيش امن نسبي نعم هناك اشكاليه مثل
ما ذكرت لك سابقا الحكومه لم يتعمد احد
افشالها الحكومه هي من افشلت ذاتها تخيلي
بان رئيس الحكومه يقول بان اكبر منجز له
هو انه استطاع ان يجلس في عدن خمس اشهر
هذه حكومه فاشله لا تستطيع ان تعمل بهذا
الشكل وبهذا المناخ وكسبت عداء من
احتضنونا وخلقوا لها شرعيه وهم المقاومه
الجنوبيه وقاده ابناء الجنوب وابناء
الشهداء هي من تعاديهم وهي من خلقت جو من
من الاستقرار وعمت الى ال اختلاق الفوضى
الظن منها بان المسمى الشرعيه وحده سوف
يخلق لها شرعيه انا احترم رايك يعني ودعني
ان انقل ما تقوله الى السيد ياسين التميمي
لعل يوضح لنا ايضا وجهه نظره هل فشلت
الحكومه في اداره هذه المناطق المستعاده
في اليمن ام جرى افشالها سيد
ياسين هي فشلت في العوده الى عدن والسبب
هو ان الامارات ترفض عوده الرئيس وترفض
تمكين حكومه من الاداء من اداء مه ك حكومه
مطلقه الصلاحيات هذه الحكومه لم تتعرض
للحرب حتى من قبل الانقلابيين بهذا القدر
الذي تواجهه اليوم من جانب الامارات في
المحافظات المحرره مجازا بطبيعه الحال نحن
لا نحتفل نحن كنا نتمنى ان نحتفل بعد
عامين بعدن المحرره عدن العاصمه عدن قبل
ان تدخل الامارات كانت عاصمه مؤقته اليوم
لم تعود عاصمه مؤقته بدليل ان الرئيس لم
يعود مساله الاسطوانات ان الحكومه فاشله
هذه هذه الحكومه التي لم تستطع ان تفتتح
القناه
التي محطه الكهرباء التي قدمتها قطر فقط
لان قطر هي التي مولت هذه المحطه ماذا
يمكن ان نقول رئيس الوزراء لم يستطيع
العوده في الوقت المحدد لان السلطات
الاماراتيه منعته من ذلك وهي اليوم تعيق
عمليه تاهيل مدينه عدن حتى لا تصبح عاصمه
وهذه واضح وضوح الشمس الامارات لا تريد
لعدن ان تصبح عاصمه سياسيه مؤقته
لليمنيين
الامن باكان الامارات السعوديه والامارات
سيد
ياسين واضح ان الامارات هي مطلقه الصلاحيه
في هذه المنطقه في في المحافظات الجنوبيه
ربما هناك انسجام ربما لكن انا اعتقد ان
الرياض اذا اعطت الضو الاخضر للامارات على
لتتصرف على نحو ما تتصرف اعتقد ان الرياض
ايضا ترتكب كارثه حقيقيه لان المتضرر
الاول والاخير هو المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هي التي توجد اليوم على الحدود
مع اليمن وما ترتبه الامارات في المحافظات
الجنوبيه هي ترتيبات سيئه للغايه اليوم
نحن على مشارف التقسيم والتجزيء ليس فقط
الجغرافي وانما التجزيء الاجتماعي هناك
احقاد تزرع اليوم بفعل التحريض الاماراتي
هناك تحديات حقيقيه ليس لان الحكومه فاشله
بل لان الامارات تريد ان تمضي اجندتها
المشبوهه في المحافظات الجنوبيه عدن لم
تعد صالحه للعيش عدن اليوم كانت تعاني من
الارهاب المنفلت اليوم تعاني من الارهاب
الموجه والارهاب الموجه الذي يسمح بدخول
وحدات مسلحه ترتز البزه العسكريه الى
البنك لكي تسطو على هذه الاموال هذه انا
اعتقد عمليات مواجهه الهدف منها هي خلط
الاوراق على الحكومه وعدم تمكينها من
القيام بدورها في عدن اعتقد ان رئيس
الوزراء اليوم يخوض معركه ليست ضد
الانقلابيين وانما معركه لكي يبقى في عدن
معركه من اجل ان تبقى الدوله من من اجل ان
تبقى هذه الرمزيه للدوله واعتقد اليوم ان
المعركه هي هل ستنجح الحكومه في البقا في
عدن ام لا وليس وهذه التساؤلات احيلها
للسيد احمد الصالح يعني هل يعني خاض
الجنوب وعدن خاضت المواجهه مع قوات الحوثي
صالح من اجل هذه
النتيجه سيدتي اولا من الخطا بمكان ان
نفرق بين الامارات وبين السعوديه التحالف
هو كله لا يتجزا مطلقا وعندما نتكلم نقول
بان الامارات تعادي والمملكه لا تعادي هذا
امر يعني مسخره ومهزله على الناس وماذا
تمسك الرياض اذا بعبد الربو منصور هادي
وتتمسك الامارات بالمجلس الانتقالي
المدعوم من قبل
ل المجلس الانتقالي الجنوبي هو واقع على
الارض وكك عادله لابناء الجنوب لا تستطيع
اي قوه على وجه الارض ان تنسف او تخرجها
من مسارها لانها قد بدات في 2007 قبل ان
ياتي الاماراتيين وقبل ان يك هنا
تحفل تعرف
بها لا نحن لن ندعي في المجلس الانتقالي
الى قيام دوله من اجل ان نطالب بالاعتراف
نحن واقع على الارض من اراد ان يتعامل
معنا فاهلا وسهلا ومن للا يريد فهذا شانه
الموضوع هذا في هذه المرحله نحن نتكلم على
شراكه حقيقيه نعم تكلم على شراكه حقيقيه
معنا مع دول التحالف ومع الشرعيه ايضا ولم
ننكر الشرعيه ولم ننسف من مكانها بالعكس
نحن استقبلنا ووضعنا مكان لهذه واحترم هذه
كرئيس جنوبي موجود وشرعيه لهدف واحد لدينا
شراكه حقيقيه من جهتين اولا في وديه العدو
الذي هو المخلوع صالح والحوثيين وثم وديه
التحالف وبالتالي كان لدينا نقاط شراكه
حقيقيه مع الشرعيه لكن الشرعيه ابت الا ان
تنسف هذا الامر ومن ثم عندما نتحدث بان
هناك اشكاليه بين الامارات والشرعيه
الشرعيه لديها مؤسساتها الاعلاميه
ومؤسساتها الدستوريه بامكان ان اتحدث عن
ذلك لماذا لم يخرج موظف واحد داخل هذه
الشرعيه ليتكلم بيقول بان الامارات تعمل
ضدهم لا يوجد اي مشكله بين الامارات
والشرعيه الى اليوم ولو كان هناك اي
اشكاليه ستحدث الشرعيه لان لديها مؤسساتها
الاعلاميه والسياسيه
والسيادة مثل ما حصل في تعز اليوم من قتل
ما بين افراد المقاومه يدل بان هناك
اشكاليه كبيره جدا اما موضوع ابناء الجنوب
والقضيه الجنوبيه هي قضيه وجدت من قبل ان
يكون هناك تحالف ا اسمح لي في الدقيقه
الاخيره ان اسمع وجهه نظر ياياسين التميمي
وفي عجاله برايك ما هو مصير مشروع الدوله
اليمنيه مشروع الدوله اليمنيه مهدد للغايه
اذا ما اذا اذا ما اصر التحالف العربي ان
يمضي عكس الاهداف التي دخل من اجلها الى
البلاد انا اعتقد ان الاوراق يمكن ان
تختلط اليمنيون لا يستطيعون ان يصبروا
اكثر من ذلك هناك مصادره لحق اليمنيين في
تقرير مصيرهم والتحالف العربي يستاثر اكثر
من اللازم بمساله تقرير المصير السياسي
بينما هو يفترض ان يطلع بدوره في الشق
السياسي بحكم القواسم
المشتركه والهواجس الامنيه المشتركه ما
نراه اليوم هو ان التحالف العربي يمضي
قدما ربما باتجاه معاكس للاهداف التي جاء
من اجلها وهنا تكمن الخطوره ولهذا نحن
نشعر بالقلق تجاه مستقبل اليمنيه شكرا لك
من اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
اليمنيه سينا تميمي ومن نيويورك الباحث
السياسي اليمني وانت ايضا عضو في الهيئه
الاعلاميه للمجلس الانتقالي شكرا جزيلا
لكما على المشاركه معنا وبذا نصل الى
نهايه الحصاد الى اللقاء